Sunday night okay so we'll be stats and
I will be talking about the Sunday night
football game on Monday morning while
you are asleep it will be Chiefs at
Seahawks a game that kept getting bigger
and bigger last week once the Chiefs
lost to the Chargers that game goes next
level once the Seahawks lost to the
49ers that game goes even higher level a
lot riding on it the Seahawks still
haven't won a playoff berth the Chiefs
are looking at either the 1 seed or the
5 seed based upon how the rest of the
season shakes out this is a huge huge
game and it's two very different styles
coming together and one of the loudest
stadiums in the NFL Patra homes gonna
get another primetime test and we'll
find out whether or not he can pass it
Chris
yeah you're right I mean it's an awesome
game this will be one of the toughest
tests he's had as a young quarterback
just as far as dealing with the
environment Seattle is so loud it will
make your brain shake at times when
you're on at the line of scrimmage I
mean that's the that's the kind of
loudness that's in that stadium so it's
electric I guess I would say this you
know the fascinating thing for the
Chiefs is they're playing the same
defense for the second week in a row
the Chargers their defensive coordinator
Gus Pat Bradley he came from Seattle
Seattle runs the same defense the
Chargers run and we just saw the Chiefs
kind of struggle finding big pass plays
against the Seahawks dot mean against
the Chargers defense so I worry about
that with Seattle and as we've seen from
Seattle all year long they are so much
better at home especially their defense
their defense let's up a lot of big
plays on the road but the the crowd and
the home-field advantage that that crowd
does give the defense at home makes them
a different team all together playing on
that field turf makes their front seven
extremely fast and I think all those
aspects the thing with the Kansas City
Chiefs like you know they gotta find
some ways to find some explosive plays
on their offense it's killing them that
they're missing Sammy Watkins I think
people forget that they're paying him
Odell
Jr money and they're not getting their
money's worth right now and they need
their offense to be healthy and hitting
on all cylinders if they want to go to
the Super Bowl because their defense is
not good and I have a hard time thinking
that they're gonna stop Seattle's
offense a whole lot Seattle can run the
ball you know and then Seattle a wide
receiver
you know I it's not like the best in
football but it's dangerous right Mike I
mean every week we see Russell Wilson
throwing bombs down the field to lock it
or Doug Baldwin or whoever it may be and
I just think because Kansas City's gonna
be worried about stopping that Seahawks
run game they're gonna have to play some
man-to-man on the back end and Russell
and the run game and everything they'll
make enough plays and I favor the
Seahawks in this one right now you
mentioned Sammy Watkins he did not
practice again on Wednesday he first
missed a game November 11 against
Arizona right with that foot problem and
then he came back for the 54-51 classic
against the Rams but he had one catch
for four yards before he left again then
since the bye week games against the
Raiders Ravens Chargers Watkins has not
played no indication when he's gonna be
back but when you take him out of the
mix it makes it so much easier to focus
on Tyreke play and they don't have
someone else who can step up and get it
done the way Watkins did and yes you
they're not getting their money's worth
he actually got a better contract than
odo Beckham jr. cuz it's shorter and and
who knows how long of a stay he's gonna
have in Kansas City if he can't play
yeah that's right I mean any time I
evaluate a team the first thing I do is
go okay who's being paid and are they
getting their money's worth out of what
you know position or area that they've
invested their money in and Kansas City
said it's offense and we're gonna out
you know out shootout you that's what
they want to do they're not into playin
defensive struggles and I think they can
win a shootout against any team in
football if Sammy Watkins is healthy but
if he's not they're not the type of team
Mike the thing I worry about with them
in this matchup and what I saw with the
Chiefs offens first two Chargers last
week the Chiefs just run their plays
they're not like a game plan specific
play or offense I should say you know as
like the the Seattle opponent last week
the San Francisco
forty-niners if anybody saw the
highlights or watch that game I know you
did stats you saw wide-open people all
over the field for the 49ers right yes
because Kyle Shanahan he knows that
Seattle scheme and he exploded exposed
some of the rules within that scheme
Kansas City doesn't look to do that him
Andy Reid he's a great offensive mind
but he just throws a barrage at placing
you and he teaches his players how to
execute those plays no matter what the
defense is and the quarterback goes ok
they played this defense this is how I
run this play and if they play this
defense this same play I run it that way
so they know how to execute all these
plays verse specific looks but they
don't come into the game with specific
game plan type plays and if they do the
same thing they did last week which was
just send people deep and the Chargers
played soft zone coverage
yeah they became stagnant and we know
Andy Reed can be a little reluctant to
stay patient with the run game at times
and I know that we've had this
discussion in the past about prime time
versus afternoon I still think there's
something different about prime time the
crowds more intense sure the moment
feels bigger and we've seen the Chiefs
now look they had the great comeback
against the Broncos back in week four
but since then the loss to the Rams in
primetime the loss to the Chargers last
week in primetime
and the loss to the Patriots earlier in
the year in prime time they weren't
blown out in any of those games all over
three points or less by way of a margin
but boy that just either you have the
ability to close the deal or you don't
and I think at a certain point if you
continue to not get it done in those
spots it kind of takes on a life of its
own and that's gonna be hovering over
this team you throw those struggles in
big games this year on top of the fact
that they haven't won a playoff game at
home since Joe Montana was the
quarterback that there is plenty of
reason for Chiefs fans to be losing
sleep as we get closer and closer to the
playoffs yeah yeah you're right
and I mean I think close the deal is
exactly the right way to put it I mean
they were up 28 to 14 and had a fourth
down on that first drive gnam that the
Chargers made it 28 21 to close the deal
they had to fourth downs on the second
drive when the game was 2821 to close
the deal and then the game they couldn't
do that in that situation they could
never make the big stop against the Rams
to kind of get off the field and give
their team a chance that way so that's
where yeah you look at it and go it is
it's tough for their defense to close
the deal their offense has to close the
deal that's what it is and without Sammy
Watkins I don't know if they're a team
that can get to the Super Bowl but I
think if they do have a healthy Sammy
Watkins I look at the Chiefs and go no
watch out for them because their offense
can be so overwhelming with all those
weapons when they are healthy that I
don't even know if it matters about
their defense they can put you in such a
tough spot early on like we saw them get
off to this great start this season
where everybody would look up and go
damn we're down 20 1 2 3 and we've tied
the ball 6 plays like how did this
happen and that's how they've
overwhelmed you to start the season and
they've kind of lost that mojo here as
of late by the time we get to Sunday
night the Chiefs will know whether or
not the number1 seed is available to
them to possibly clinch because if the
Chargers lose on Saturday night if the
Texans lose or tie earlier in the day to
the Eagles the Chiefs will know you win
and they have the number 1 seed and then
they can kind of coast if they choose to
there's always some risk in coasting in
week 17 if you have the by maybe by the
time it's time to play again you may not
be as sharp as you need to be but the
Chiefs will have a pretty good idea
what's going on
yeah time the game starts yeah it does
seem they will I mean that's that's of
course one of the great races to watch
right now and I mean I think the other
just for conversation purposes I think
the interesting thing is what happens if
the Chargers and the Chiefs both lose
this weekend right and then they fall to
you know they're both at 11 and for two
wins the tiebreaker and I don't even
know the answer of this who wins the
tiebreaker between the two AFC West
teams and let's say the Houston Texans
if they all end up having the same
record when it's all said and done
because that's right the Chiefs have the
head the head-to-head tie breakers one
to one right the Chiefs have the better
division record for now so they've got
the edge and and so I it could get more
complicated after yeah because the
Chiefs have the Raider
and the Chargers have the Broncos but
the Texans have the door open yeah
that's the one thing we're focused so
much on Chiefs vs. Chargers i1c the
Texans who have never even had a bye
week in the postseason could end up the
number one seed so there and this as
well and the Seahawks as I said they
still haven't nailed down
their own playoff berth and they're
gonna be trying to do that as well
talking about that Chiefs defense before
we take a break yeah sure very fully
participate in practice for the first
time all year right he played half of
the game on on the last Thursday against
the Chargers and I know how bad the
backend of the Chiefs defense is does
having Barry back does that help it does
enough it does help does it make you
feel better about the Chiefs defense yes
it does make me feel better when I see
him out there playing a full game and
healthy he has a presence about him he
did a nice little job in the first half
last week in that football game before
he came out for good and kudos to the
Chiefs for not trying to you know overdo
it his first game back and then
reactivating the injury where they don't
have him for the playoffs I think that
was a smart move but yes Mike I mean not
only communication purposes when I watch
film he's telling he's the quarterback
of the defense he just got an uncanny
ability to read and react to plays he
even helps out in the run game he's so
quick to diagnose the run plays he's
down there in the hole just like a
linebacker right away and I at least
think when they get in the playoffs and
he is totally a hundred percent that he
could be a guy on a big third in four
who could man up with Antonio Gates or
Rob Gronkowski and go nope you're gonna
have to go somewhere else and they don't
really have that guy so that's the added
in you know incentive he can bring to to
that defense
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports